s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup bonsoir à tous je pense
que la voix vous a un peu choqué
dès le départ parce qu'il y a une voix
puissante derrière
je suis une super héroïne et dans le
film tant que le brave n'a pas gagné le
film n'est pas terminé je suis Nadine
Zorro imaginez mes parents ont bien
trouvé le nom Zoro et ce nom depuis
toute petite ma inspiré m'a conduit
parce que je me suis dit pourquoi une
personne peut avoir un nom de
super-héros et ne pas vivre une vie de
super héroïne c'est pas possible donc
pour moi le destin était déjà tracé
Nadine Zorro devait être une super
héroïne et depuis petit je me suis
toujours demandé par quel moyen est-ce
que je peux influencer ma communauté et
je vous dirai ça c'est juste une petite
confession à côté je me disais avant je
vais influencer peu importe si c'est
positif ou négatif mais je ne vais pas
passer de manière
oublier sur cette terre et j'ai vécu de
cette manière et ma façon de voir les
choses et de m'organiser tourner autour
de cela
Nadine Zorro c'était cette petite fille
là qui avait sa petite place je sais pas
si tout le monde est comme moi est-ce
que vous aviez une classe avec des
cailloux à la maison donc vous n'avez
pas sa personne je suis la seule donc
depuis toute petite
CPS CP2 dès la maternelle même puisque
mes deux parents sont instituteurs
j'aimais voir les personnes enseignées
et ça me fascinait et donc quand je me
levais c'était de créer des classes je
place les cailloux comment classe et
j'ai un tableau et j'enseigne à mes
élèves et j'étais très sérieuse très
stricte surtout donc je frappais les
cailloux certains mourraient à l'hôpital
dans le processus je vous explique un
peu où est-ce que cette rigueur est
venue dans ma façon de faire et donc
ayant grandi à Bingerville c'est ça qui
a raison de bien j'ai envie peut-être
dans la salle
j'étais tout le temps inspirée parce que
les enseignants faisaient je me
demandais à chaque fois comment est-ce
que j'arrive à apprendre à travailler
sur mes propres compétences pour pouvoir
faire bénéficier ma communauté je me
suis toujours posé la question de
comment est-ce qu'on fait qu'une
personne qui est née dans une famille
recomposée de 10 personnes avec des
parents très modestes arrivent à monter
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à lui passer
des leçons lui faire avoir accès à des
opportunités pour que ces personnes
grandissent et est ce potentiel là et
c'est ce que je me suis donné comme
mission la mission d'impacter
positivement la vie des individus leur
permet de voir un exemple de quelqu'un
qui a grandi par le travail aujourd'hui
je suis directrice et cofondatrice
d'impact à Abidjan qui est un incubateur
accélérateur de start-up depuis 2019
nous avons accompagné plus de 200
entreprises en Côte d'Ivoire alors
croissance je suis aussi directrice du
programme digif femme j'espère que les
personnes connaissent ce programme mais
c'est un programme qui travail à
l'autonomisation des femmes des femmes
parlent le digital et c'est un peu
étrange lorsque les hommes me demandent
si je suis développée ou est-ce que j'ai
travaillé dans le digital est-ce que moi
je maîtrise la technologie et je leur ai
dit non j'apprends comme vous je
recherche mais ce que je sais c'est que
lorsqu'il y a un certain courant et que
la société en train de se déplacer vers
un certain objectif si vous voulez faire
partie de l'élite vous devez sauter dans
le bateau dès le départ et ça c'est une
leçon que j'ai apprise et j'essaie de
partager cette leçon au milieu de jeûne
autour de moi avec des femmes
aujourd'hui notre objectif c'est de
former plus de 16000 femmes en Côte
d'Ivoire aux compétences numériques
Nadine Zorro c'est cette femme là qui a
été très très depuis très longtemps
convaincu que une seule personne peut
faire beaucoup de choses si ces
personnes arrivent à comprendre le
mécanisme derrière l'influence
l'influence et je répète un peu ce que
mon prédestin a dit tout à l'heure c'est
déjà de donner ce que vous avez de
manière authentique c'est de rester vous
et c'est le votre vous qui va conduire
au changement des personnes autour de
vous et je le fais aujourd'hui avec ma
façon de fonctionner de manière générale
l'authenticité cette authenticité là qui
me permet d'être la révélation directe
de ce que je pense dans ma tête dans ma
manière de fonctionner chaque jour de ne
pas avoir ce décalage là entre ce que
vous pensez être et ce que vous faites
et donc j'arrive à travailler
continuellement pour m'assurer que mes
pensées par rapport à moi et c'est moi
la super héroïne ne sont pas détachés de
ce que je fais chaque jour
étant comme Robin des Bois je me lève
chaque matin et je me sacrifie pour les
personnes autour de moi et je me demande
comment est-ce qu'une parole peut
changer la vie de quelqu'un comment
est-ce qu'une petite technique peut
est-ce qu'une petite formation peut être
donner à un entrepreneur pour que son
entreprise grandisse et que des milliers
de personnes sont employées par cette
entreprise là et c'est tout un travail
continue mais c'est cette authenticité
là de ne pas être dans un objectif de
plaire de ne pas être dans un objectif
de devenir ce que le monde pense que je
dois devenir mais d'être la personne que
je pense être et de donner ces personnes
là entièrement avec tous mes efforts et
excellence à la communauté autour de moi
et c'est ce que je fais chaque jour avec
le programme ensuite en dehors de
l'authenticité c'est la valeur sûre
est-ce que ce que je dis j'arrive à le
faire est-ce que lorsque je fais des
promesses à ma communauté j'arrive à
travailler et arriver aux résultats que
j'ai promis à la personne autour de moi
sans élément très important et on ne le
dit pas assez on est dans un
environnement je dirais de VI si on peut
le prendre comme ça mais on a des
personnes qui disent des choses et
ensuite qui font des promesses mais qui
ne se traduisent pas automatiquement en
résultats on a des personnes qui vont
aujourd'hui travailler à devenir ou
apparaître influent au lieu de
travailler et démontrer cette influence
là donc pour moi l'une des valeurs sûres
et importantes dans l'influence c'est de
faire des promesses qui seront ensuite
des vrais résultats et c'est la raison
pour laquelle aujourd'hui dans
l'écosystème entrepreneurial et même
dans le secteur même de la finance
digitale où j'ai travaillé pendant plus
de 5 ans on me connaît comme une
personne qui livre
lorsqu'elle dit qu'elle va faire quelque
chose elle arrive au bout mais pourquoi
c'est le résultat d'une éducation
rappelez-vous on retourne à l'histoire
de la petite fille qui formait ses
cailloux et qui a grandi avec des
parents enseignants qui s'assurer que
l'excellence faisait partie de nos
valeurs et l'excellence pourquoi ma mère
disait
elle n'était pas selon elle aimable elle
me disait tout le temps les gens ne vont
pas forcément t'aimeront imaginez vous
voyez le visage je suis pas très
souriante je suis pas forcément la plus
ouverte mais la seule chose que tu peux
faire pour que le monde te cherche c'est
d'être excellente tu n'as pas besoin de
te faire aimer comment est-ce que tu
arrives à travailler et t'assurer que
ton travail tes valeurs les valeurs que
tu veux mettre en avant sont alignés
avec la personne que tu es et c'est ce
travail continue l'excellence va être ce
qui va faire la différence entre une
personne qui se présente influente et
une personne qui influe vraiment pas qui
influencent vraiment pas ton résultat
et c'est une grande différence et moi
pour moi cette excellence là fait partie
des valeurs sûres de quelqu'un qui
influence réellement après c'est le
service
vous voulez être influent devenir un bel
art pour votre communauté
à chaque moment lorsqu'il y a des
demandes lorsqu'il y a des travaux
lorsqu'il y a une certaine intervention
soyez c'est la même ces personnes qui
arrivent à se lever et à faire le
travail pour les autres soyez une
personne influente qui accompagne les
autres dans leur influence
et moi ce que je fais personnellement
c'est de me mettre à l'arrière-plan je
ne veux même pas qu'on me voit je veux
aider les personnes influentes à devenir
beaucoup plus influente on travaille
pour ces personnes là je veux être une
personne qui permet aux autres personnes
de briller beaucoup plus parce que moi
derrière tout ce que je veux faire c'est
travailler mon travail de super héroïne
ne s'est pas un travail
visible c'est pas un travail de
visibilité sans travail de résultats et
ces résultats là parle depuis plusieurs
années ce qui me vaut aujourd'hui
à 30 ans étant directrice d'un programme
de peu de 3 millions de dollars sur
trois ans et géré par des bailleurs
internationaux c'est le résultat de
toute cette constance là en termes de
résultats excellents pour qu'on puisse
arriver à vous faire confiance vous
devez montrer sur une longue période
aussi que vous délivrez avec excellence
cette petite Nadine du quartier Blanchon
de Bingerville est aujourd'hui un
exemple pour les jeunes de sa communauté
mais pas un exemple comme une influence
comme on le voit aujourd'hui mais un
exemple de résilience
et tout de résilience parce que étant
dernier d'une famille de 10 personnes et
jumelles et ça c'est la partie je pense
la plus intéressante de si je mets avec
un garçon et mon jumeau était super
talentueux il avait tout pris au moins
en fait beaucoup plus grand il était
plus beau c'était bizarre en plus je
suis une femme il était plus beau que
moi beaucoup plus grand que moi plus
beau il savait chanter il savait danser
il savait dessiner et ma mère disait
quand c'était petite certaines fois
j'essayais d'attirer l'attention sur moi
et donc j'essaie de danser pour dire
regardez-moi un peu et lui se moquait
désormais toi tu sais rien faire du tout
en grandissant je me suis dit j'ai pas
de talent
j'ai bon mon talent c'est ma voix un peu
en parlant super pouvoir mais j'ai pas
de talent comme ce que la société
appelle des talents ce que la société
met en avant comme des talents
artistiques je n'ai pas ce type de
talent comment est-ce que je fais pour
remonter comment est-ce que je fais pour
influencer si je ne me base pas sur les
éléments qui ne demandent pas de talent
et c'est comme ça que toutes ces
progressions tous les résultats que nous
voyons aujourd'hui
ont commencé à se former parce que je me
suis dit ma seule chance c'est d'être
discipliné dans le travail ma seule
chance c'est d'être excellente je serai
pas la plus belle je serai pas celle qui
s'est chanter comment est-ce que je fais
pour devenir cette personne là qui ne
disparaît pas de la surface de la terre
quand je vais mourir personne ne parlera
plus de moi c'est de me focaliser sur
ces éléments là qui ne demandent pas de
talent ces éléments là qui demandent pas
un réseau ces éléments qui demandent
juste que tu travailles et que tu t'y
mettes et c'est quelque chose que je
fais
je disais se mettre au travail pour les
autres aussi on parle d'influence et
qu'on le dit généralement on met une
personne dans l'avant comment est-ce que
je me mets derrière ces personnes
comment est-ce que j'arrive à influencer
dans les domaines où je suis influente
et ça peut être aussi simple que je
connais la meilleure vendeuse de la
qualité
l'influence c'est vraiment
l'authenticité dans la manière dont vous
êtes je ne peux que donner ce que j'ai
et j'ai pas grandi dans un environnement
où j'ai tout le réseau qu'il faut j'ai
pas grandi dans un environnement où j'ai
des parents qui peuvent me pousser mais
ce que je sais c'est que dans mon petit
quartier de Bingerville si tu cherches
le meilleur gars base je peux t'envoyer
là-bas tu cherches quand je peux
t'envoyer dans tel endroit et ça pour
moi c'est ça le début de l'excellence et
de l'influence c'est de commencer déjà
avec le peu que vous avez et le rendre à
disposition de la le maître à
disposition de votre communauté ne
diminuez pas ce que vous avez le peu et
juste ces vendeuse de gars là je vous
dis ça peut créer une ouverture énorme
parce que les plus influents les plus
connus les plus grands vont vous
contacter lorsqu'on cherche une vendeuse
de Garba et ça c'est un positionnement
que vous prenez dans votre authenticité
vous restez sur ce que vous savez faire
mon travail d'héroïne
s'est développé aussi par la poursuite
continuelle
de la connaissance je ne m'arrête pas à
ce que je connais j'ai commencé par
étudier dans le marketing je suis arrivé
en finance digitale ensuite dans la
gestion de projet aujourd'hui je suis
dans la gestion de projet mais j'ai des
initiatives en finance digitale je sais
pas développer mais je sais qu'on se
voit et cette expérience là je l'ai j'ai
fait des recherches et j'ai appris
n'hésitez surtout pas à bénéficier des
personnes qui sont autour de vous c'est
une question
d'amour aussi l'amour c'est pas
seulement le donner mais c'est aussi le
recevoir et pour être une personne
influente vous devez être ouvert à
recevoir à recevoir des personnes qui
sont autour de vous et pour pouvoir
recevoir vous devez ouvrir les yeux vous
devez les voir
l'influence c'est de pouvoir aussi
regarder une personne une personne
banale et voir le potentiel de ces
personnes pour vous permettre à vous de
vous développer et ça se fait avec de
l'empathie une personne influente qui
n'a pas d'empathie ne va pas faire long
feu l'empathie c'est cette capacité là
ressentir pour les autres à regarder les
personnes beaucoup plus profondément que
les yeux à regarder les personnes en
dehors de ce que la société définit
comme une personne de valeur et lorsque
vous arrivez à le faire ces personnes
vont vous donner le peu qu'elles ont de
leur super pouvoir je reviens toujours
sur les super pouvoir parce que pour moi
nous individuellement nous sommes des
dieux et nous avons des supers pouvoirs
chacun de nous a des supers pouvoirs qui
doivent être mis à disposition de notre
environnement et c'est ce que je fais de
manière continue si mon super pouvoir
c'est être stricte et m'assurer que mon
équipe livre les choses à temps et de
prendre une méthode militaire pour que
le résultat se fait ça sera mon super
pouvoir c'est ce sur quoi je vais me
focaliser pour permettre à ma communauté
de grandir pour permettre à ces 16000
femmes là de devenir des femmes qui ont
des vies transformées nous avons
aujourd'hui dans le programme des femmes
qui ont arrêté d'aller à l'école depuis
qu'elles avaient 18 ans elles ont 50 ans
et aujourd'hui elles arrivent à coder
imaginer quelqu'un qui n'avait pas
d'ordinateur qui savait même pas comment
est-ce qu'un ordinateur fonctionne et
c'est ces petits changements là de voir
des personnes qui avaient même perdu
espoir en leur vie mais à cause d'une
petite formation arrive à se transformer
arrive à faire à faire bénéficier toute
leur famille et toute leur communauté
pour moi c'est ça l'influence et c'est
le travail que je fais avec mes
différentes organisations et je ne
pourrais le faire que si je travaille à
moi-même mes propres compétences et
aussi si je m'assure de rester
authentique et aligner à ma vision
personnelle d'impacter parce que pour
moi ma mission de vie c'est d'impacter
positivement la société avec ce que j'ai
c'est de rester une belle là de l'impact
merci beaucoup